all right thank you thank you Michael
Mike works yeah cool okay so yeah my
biggest achievement has been the last
two years I have not gone to the KY
conference and yet have won the most
popular tweeter competition that which
is a real thing it's I'm very proud of
that so for the last 15 years or so I've
been working in this domain of
accessibility which I think is really
interesting I think it is really well
connected to kind of AI and machine
learning especially as we develop
interactive systems and think about well
how are people really going to use and
benefit from what we use what we
developed within machine learning and so
today I'm going to take basically two
sections of a talk so the first talk I
want to introduce you just kind of how
I've come to think about accessibility
as a field and then I'm going to apply
some of the lessons from that in AI and
machine learning just hopefully convince
you that they're connected and also
hopefully connect convince you that
there's a really big opportunity right
now I think to apply what's happened in
machine learning over the last few years
to accessibility and I'll give you some
examples about how I'm thinking about
that all right so first a bit of an
introduction into accessibility so
whenever somebody gives a talk on
accessibility they inevitably have a
slide that's kind of like this one that
says things like over 15 percent of the
population has a disability so
accessibility is really important you
have or probably will have if you're
lucky a disability sometime in your life
as you get older many people develop
what is essentially a disability and
having walked around a little bit on the
Stanford campus I can tell you that
there's a lot of people experiencing
what we would call situational
impairments right now looking down at
their phone walking maybe driving you
know riding the bikes with their phone
and whatever else you're trying to do I
think that's really important too but I
but I really push back on this notion
that accessibility is niche that it's
kind of this narrow thing I think
accessibility is very big and so this
little dot which I just had there
didn't explain is not accessibility
right so this is the narrow set of
interactions that we assume with our
devices that everybody has maybe high
visual acuity and high motor dexterity
and everything else is essentially
accessibility right so getting you to be
able to interact with any other set of
abilities is kind of in this domain of
accessibility and so for me
accessibility is very intimately tied to
human-computer interaction as a field
right and so if we look at some of the
really great innovative important
developments in HCI over our history
what we see is not only the introduction
of really amazing new interaction
possibilities so for instance you know
Engelbert mother of all demos right this
is kind of what gets a lot of us in HCI
super excited and I'm super excited
about it at the same time what happens
when you introduce a mouse and you
introduce a visual display and the
graphical user interface what you've
done effectively is locked in a set of
abilities that then we assume going
forward and that's really important it
was actually really important that we
did that to make deep sustained progress
in HCI and it's been wildly successful
at the same time these are ability
assumptions that accessibility has to
deal with and it keeps happening right
so you know another really amazing
development in HCI introduction the best
pointing device in the world we're gonna
use a pointing device that we're all
born with were born with ten of them
where he use our fingers alright so
introducing an iPhone right use your
fingers amazing new kind of interaction
with our mobile devices it works really
really well at the same time you're not
everybody can do that and so you know
one way this has sort of been humorously
Illustrated is with this kind of maybe
you've seen this this little figure or
these kinds of figures before you have
this how does your computer see you and
like in this case this is a you know a
little little person here with one giant
finger with presumably high motor
dexterity
you know one eye they can kind of see
flat surfaces some ears that you maybe
listen with
so so one way I've started sort of
jokingly but you know somewhat seriously
referring to this is you know these sort
of ability assumptions are hcis
original sin right this is what we've
sort of been working against an
accessibility now for years and so
accessibility one way of thinking of it
is accessibility is the long slog
against ability assumptions so we've
locked in the set of abilities how do we
develop devices that work in different
ways so some things that accessibility
cares about so the grand challenges of
accessibility we care about expanding
into new modalities right and there's
lots of people working on well let's say
we didn't we someone can't use a
touchscreen someone can't use a keyboard
can't use a mouse what other kinds of
modalities can we use so tactile input
for instance I've got to see some really
great examples in Sean's lab the other
is you know for better or worse we do
have all of this stuff out there that
assume certain abilities and so we need
to be able to translate between it and
I'll go into a little bit more about why
that is but if we have something that is
assumed to work in one way how do we
make it work in a different way as we
develop more and more features so you
know I think it's really great that a
lot of devices you know like iPhone has
50 accessibility features that change in
all kinds of different ways how you use
it how do people know about those right
do people know like what sets gonna work
for me and then even if we come up with
really great solutions there's this
immense legacy problem where all this
stuff is just out in the world like I
don't even know I haven't actually
played with it but like there's a whole
panel in front of me right this is
almost certainly is an accessible in all
kinds of ways we gonna replace every
single panel we replace this panel
replace all this stuff there's all these
books that are printed that everyone's
lost the digital version of lots of
legacy problems out there so how do we
deal with that so when new technology is
introduced one thing we do in
accessibility is kind of race to figure
out well how are we gonna make that
accessible and so this is kind of an old
example but I really like it it's a
project that I worked on with Sean cane
and je crois Brock when I was at
University of Washington about 12 years
ago and the idea here was that you know
the iPhone will come out and we really
wanted to be able to use it non-visual
right so at the time there was no screen
reader on it this is all change now but
how are we gonna do that and so we
developed this system called slide rule
I'll play a video of it working takes a
second I think we're gonna open up this
slide rule app and now we're in a
completely well so so the the couple of
things that this does right so it
repurposes this touch screen is a touch
sensitive surface it allows you to
explore with your finger and importantly
and it uses this introduces this idea of
risk free exploration so now moving your
finger around doesn't activate things it
allows you to hear what's under your
finger and then we use a second tap to
actually select that thing one of the
other things we noticed is once you are
freed from this visual space of the
existing graphical user interface you
can actually fit a lot more stuff on
there so I know it was obvious but when
he was going through the the phonebook
each item in the phonebook is now the
pixel or the the the input resolution as
opposed to the visual resolution so you
could actually fit you know a huge phone
book on a single screen as opposed to
having to scroll around anyway so this
is this was really fun and it's just an
example of oh how do we adapt or how do
we think about like using some of these
devices in different ways I have a fun
little picture we just got the impact
award the ten year at impact award at
assets and so this is Sean Jake and me
and holding up flex anyway so now this
sort of interaction or some of these
ideas from this sort of interaction are
available on your iPhone on your Android
phone and it's embedded in a program we
called a screen reader which allows non
visual access to an otherwise graphical
user interface and so it's got this name
screen reader because at least initially
in the development of
screen reading technology the idea was
that software people would build
software and would literally intercept
the pixels that were being written into
the screen and sometimes into the screen
buffer sometimes they were able to get
it before it was turned into pixels like
text before it got turned into pixels
and it would then convert it to speech
as you'll see here in a second or
professional Braille so not all
assistive technologies are screen
readers but I do think it's really
helpful to think about well how does a
screen reader work because some of the
ideas are on round trip oh okay well
here's round training reader reading
round trip one way see apps next
Saturday's a lot January so so at a high
level right it comes up with some sort
of you know representation of the
graphic user interface if you've ever
built a web page you might think of this
as sort of the Dom of the user interface
and then it traverses it if if it's a
tree then it's a depth-first traversal
of the tree it has a question you know
changing the GUI to voice I was all of
just that transitioning from a textual
interface to a GUI
cut off a lot of visually impaired
people that have found employment in
that area um because it actually fit
some of our skills better or is it do
you want you this is the biggest
different ability in the population or
easier to attack like I'm curious
whether you know I says people age we
start to see people getting worse and
more solutions so it's kind of broader
than just let's say people or their
other you know motor or another
impairments that are bigger yes I mean
these are really this is a really good
set of questions so one is why do we
focus or why am I talking about screen
reading one reason is because I think
it's one of the quickest to understand
of you've got this graphical user
interface usually you don't have to
convince people too much that a person
who's blind can't see that
and then thinking about well how do you
convey that information and you've got
this underlying representation and you
have to somehow convert it to voice many
of the other kinds of accessibility
features that you might have so I
mentioned you know however many on all
your devices work using many of the same
underlying things right so if I am
somebody who is a switch control user
for instance who I have a set one or
more switches that allow me to go
through the user interface it works
actually a pretty similar way where
instead of you know voicing things it
visually shows me a progression across
you know different possible user
interface elements and then I can choose
how that that progression goes and I can
choose which one I want to select and
there are others right so we offer
obviously there's ways to change how
works how what kind of motor dexterity
assumptions there are there's endless
features for magnification for changing
colors for doing all of these these
sorts of things so there was a big
switch from when there were text-based
interfaces like command-line interfaces
where it was at least there was
obviously still some problems but it was
a little more straightforward to create
like a screen reader experience for a
text command-line interface when you go
into a graphical user interfaces at
least initially a lot of the semantics
were just gone in pixels right and then
there's been decades now I think to to
reverse some of that where you have
access to a better representation of the
GUI that you can convert to different
forms I think the reason why we focus a
lot on gooeys is because this is still
the dominant way that things are
represented right and you find a number
of examples out there where you could
imagine well let's let's create a whole
separate web page and people do this and
it's always a bad idea
create a whole separate website for
people who are using screen readers for
instance this happens actually this is
blackboards solution for a solution for
accessibility almost always it works
differently you have access to different
stuff and so the trade-off that people
have been willing to make and I think
it's important and it makes sense that
they make it is to put up with these
transformations because at least that
gives you access to the thing that
everyone else has access to
and that most of the focus is put on
yeah try to sort of discuss or measure
like what you could call an
accessibility gap like imagine that you
give me this Delta app and then you also
you know split me into a parallel realm
where you give me the blacked out
version of it you train me on the screen
reader and I think it highly-trained
with it and then you're comparing me on
say a number of tasks like you look at
the Delta in terms of number of errors
I've made or how long it takes me to get
something done like do we know like how
big that gap actually is yeah well I
have some so I have some slides for that
so I'm gonna I'm gonna
maybe I'll just skip ahead to this a
little bit so one of the big problems
right is that none of this works unless
you have a good representation right and
so I have some slides about that let me
get actually what I'm gonna get back to
your question cuz yes there's a
difference with a lot of people looked
at it it's basically worse right but I
can quantify that a lot like yeah but
but I'll get back to I do have a slide
ooh have some slides on that so so one
of the challenges is that there are just
these persistent problems in creating
that representation that any of these
accessibility tools can actually work
over right so one of my first projects
in graduate school was a project that
looked to try to make the images on
webpages create an alternative textual
description for them so that the screen
reader could read them right this is I
think this is the UCLA website and
basically all of the text and all of the
like navigation information on website
were images and so the screen reader had
no idea what they were and so we came up
with a number of approaches to try to
try to fix this interesting thing is you
know flash-forward to 2020 and we're
still using images across you know the
web and our mobile devices you know
Michael mentioned I use Twitter a lot a
lot of people share images on Twitter up
until about two years ago you couldn't
even add an alternative text description
for images now you can so there's a
little button now if you you go there
the amazing thing we crawled like you
know nine over nine million tweets you
know the joke is we were going to write
on this little bar like
any of those you know image tweets had
alt text but you couldn't see it if we
did that and so we had to blow up this
little area in this big box and that
black dot is the you know one thousand
of the nine million tweets that actually
have alt text because no one does it why
don't they do it well lots of different
reasons that we got into in this this
paper but one of them is that you know
it's Twitter made an interesting design
decision so you don't just automatically
get access to this alternative text
option you have to go through a process
it looks like this
so three menus down you can turn it on
and then what that means is that you now
have the option to provide an
alternative text description if you
choose to do that there's all kinds of
problems after that right but basically
no one gets past this step and so people
still don't necessarily write good alt
text descriptions and they don't know
how to do it and all these things but
most people don't even know about it
yeah your co-author on other paper do
you have ideas of what the political
issues were for Microsoft turning it on
it seems automatically in PowerPoint
like it prompts me to do alt text versus
Twitter not making it easy
in that way yeah I think that there's a
lot of things going on many of them
which you might guess I don't know
exactly what happened within Twitter
we of course have tried to ask them and
not not gotten so far but and they're
doing better now I think this paper and
maybe some other pushback they are doing
a little bit better it's not only by
default yet for everyone yet but one
thing I've come to learn having kind of
straddle academia and Industry and
accessibility for a while is that the
way the way accessibility actually
happens in an organization is when that
organization decides that accessibility
is a value it doesn't mean just hiring
an accessibility team if they're not
empowered to make real change it doesn't
unfortunately mean that even
well-meaning individual
who's maybe knew that this wasn't I mean
Twitter has an accessibility team right
and they knew I mean they know this is
an issue but how do you they get
empowered to make changes right and you
might speculate well why wouldn't they
want that little add image description
button on the the tweet people might
think it's well what is that is that
kanuha will that confuse people you know
the the cynic and me if you follow me on
Twitter the tweet would be something
like they probably did an a/b test and
0.1% of fewer tweets were sent and so
they decided they'd rather have 0.1% of
alt text provided right but but I don't
know but I do think that if it's not a
value it doesn't get done and so you
look at the companies that do well in
accessibility and they usually do have a
real value behind it - to Michael's
point that's kind of all feeds in with
each other right so there's kind of this
notion and this was first expressed to
me in this way by TV Raman who's a blind
scientist at Google this idea of first
and second class abilities right so
first class is the ones that sort of we
see by default so you see high visual
acuity you see high motor dexterity and
then you get stuff added on and it's
possible to use but it's never quite as
good for a lot of different reasons it's
hard to make it good if you've designed
it one way and then someone comes along
and they can't have access to everything
not every experience gets to be designed
for every single modality there's other
ways they're just not as good so to
Michael's question right has someone
study so we did a study I won't get into
all the details but you know across
different tasks on the web where we
controlled you know if it was designed
to be an easy task a hard task an
inaccessible task or an impossible task
which is I'll explain basically the
blind users took between you know two
and three four times as long to complete
complete the task and the one of one
outcome of the task was deciding that it
was impossible right and so one trick
there and one of the points of the paper
beyond just demonstrating that it takes
longer
is if something's inaccessible it can
actually be pretty confusing to know is
it inaccessible or unavailable right and
so the the title of the paper is you
know the effect of not knowing what you
don't know on web accessibility because
if I go to a web page I'm looking for
you know a phone number of a pizza shop
or something and there's really hard
it's really hard for me to know is the
phone number not there or is the phone
number you know Express it an image or a
flash like flash or something else that
just doesn't work and so so we were
looking at that another thing that I
think is just interesting and bringing
up these these points and accessibility
is uh you know sometimes we're in this
kind of related awkward position of
designing what users don't want which is
really an athame to HCI and so so one
example just a little quick story of
where this came up for me we so a few
years ago we recognized you know there's
all of these speech control devices
coming out both sort of the platforms
like Alexa and Google now and Siri and
all these things but also you know at
the time especially it wasn't quite
consolidated and so there were all of
just these random things you could get
there were speech controlled like we
found like light bulbs and like
appliances like your microwave would
have its own like speech recognition
chip on it and I started thinking
basically you know it's kind of this
history that I've led you toward what's
gonna happen when these are just out in
the world right there's gonna be people
who can't speak and be understood by
these devices who are put in situations
where that's the only option right and
it is the case now there are some hotels
I think the ones I found here are here
in Silicon Valley where you know your
hotel room is speech enabled so you can
turn the lights and the thermostat and
whatever when you get to the room
I don't know offhand is if there's an
accessible way maybe you get put in
another hotel room that hasn't updated
recently that's you know accessible I
don't really know but anyway so the you
know these things are not accessible
right so Alexa I'll pick on because
there's not been a way to alternatively
control Alexa so with things like Siri
you can type to it go now I think you
can type to it and so I look at that and
it's like oh this is a big problem we
did some work on in this case we were
targeting people who were
who had characteristic deaf accent it's
not understood by these devices and you
know we we explore different ways I
think there's really interesting work
happen in different places like Google
has a big project now in a typical
speech looking at could you actually
make speech recognition work for all
kinds of different types of speech but
at the time that was seem pretty far off
and it was really hard and so you know I
I had this idea of like well what if
what if we just had like your phone like
your phone could produce text-to-speech
so Alexa doesn't support type 2 type 2
Alexa but like if you your phone could
convert text to tech with text to speech
to speech it could talk to Alexa you
could tell her it could turn on the
light bulb or whatever and then Alexa
could talk back and your phone could
recognize that speech with speech
recognition and at least you'd have a
way to do it right so great and there's
like kind of interesting interaction
challenges there too because you don't
know like if I'm typing something and
gets spoken out like I don't know if it
spoke the right thing if Alexa
understood it Lexus has something back I
don't know if like what it actually said
is what I got so there's kind of these
these different things and so I I put
together one of our masters teams to
kind of explore this problem right and
then I connected them to people
local and Pittsburgh in the deaf
community who you know could be
potential users of this thing and the
immediate feedback was like why would we
ever want that that sounds terrible this
is like why would I want to type on my
phone to talk to this thing and have
that thing talk back and then read it
when all that stuff's gonna break like I
want to use sign language I want to use
gestures I want to do something else and
I'm like yeah I know but like all this
stuff is just gonna be out in hotel
rooms and it places or your friend's
house is gonna have this thing and it's
not gonna have like sign language
recognition which is a incredibly large
hard way off problem isn't this
necessary right and it's like in this
weird case I'm arguing basically ignore
your users they didn't do that to their
credit they didn't ignore their users
but at the same time like we don't we
didn't have this solution right so I
don't know what the right answer was
here but it's a really tricky challenge
that we come up with a lot where we're
in this position potentially of
designing something that users don't
want
all right next challenge discoverability
so Michael mentioned this screen reader
that I built when I was a PhD student it
was as web-based screen reader the idea
is yeah you don't have to buy a screen
reader you could be it could access it
from any computer and that was kind of
the advantage of it you know it sounded
kind of like this anywhere has loaded
three headings one link welcome to web
anywhere heading one web anywhere alpha
release might be anywhere has been
initialized anyway it's kind of fun you
know I got the chance to build a screen
reader I can tell people I built a
screen reader from you know start to
finish and it's learned a lot from doing
that but for in the case of
discoverability my point here is once I
did this we put it out it got some
attention and they started getting all
of these emails and the emails weren't
like oh wow that's really great I can
access this thing on the web from any
computer it was like oh wow I'm so glad
there's finally a solution for people
who are blind to be able to access
computers and it's like a lot of emails
right my first experience with how
people just don't know about this stuff
and why why should they write it's not
out there it's not and you know we did
another project on you know making
content on the web a little bit bigger
so that people could see it easier and
we we ran a study with older adults so
in this case 55 plus only 2% knew how to
make basically how to do command+ to
make the web bigger right so 2% that's a
feature that's on everybody's web
browser and most people would benefit a
lot just from you know increasing the
font a little bit they didn't know how
to do it because it's not there it's
like not discoverable and so there's
this huge problem so even as we develop
solutions some solutions that actually
work pretty well right like just making
the font size bigger a little bit helps
a lot of people it's on all of your
devices now it doesn't even matter what
device you have this isn't everything
and almost nobody knows that it's there
so how do we fix that I love I there's
these interesting parallels to draw
alright so this is a this is the tactile
graphics project that I was not part of
but my my advisor Richard Ladner at
University Washington did a lot of with
and the idea was essentially there's all
of these science textbooks that you're
expected to use if you're in any point
along your education and if you want to
make that accessible to a person who's
blind you got a convert Verta to attack
attack
form which is some complexity in you got
to make it the right size got to fit the
Braille all this stuff but what's
amazing it was amazing at the time was
that you know all of this stuff was
built with digital tools and yet they'd
have access to any of that and so the
standard process was you'd get the
physical book you cut the binding off
and then somebody would go through
scanning the text but then for the
graphics it was hard and so the approach
here was basically take the picture of
the the figure and then run through this
kind of human workflow to then generate
a tactile version of it that could then
be printed but this is like not changing
right so one of the things we've noticed
recently is you know sometimes maybe if
you don't want to attribute the the
source of your your your retweet people
will take like screenshots of tweets
share them on Twitter you know people
will always like the reading news
articles and they'll take a screenshot
of that or maybe you want to you know
take a screenshot of some part of the
user interface so that you can help
somebody use it again you've now taken
something that because of all this rich
work that's happened and creating that
underlying structured representation of
the user interface it's sort of
accessible or at least convertible to
something accessible and now you've
captured it in a way that's just pixels
and then you've Reshard it making it not
accessible anymore and so my students
who geez re-implemented the screenshot
tool on Android and then on as part of
Mozilla web browser to basically as you
take the screenshot capture the
structured information and then embed it
wasn't many ways you could do this but
one way is just embed it in the exif
data so that it's there and you know
unfortunately a lot of people will strip
the exif data off but if you didn't do
that then you know you'd still have it
at least potentially carrying along
there's all kinds of clever things you
can do to get around that problem clever
things you can do about like well what
if somebody later kind of crops out some
of the webpage too or that screenshot
that they've taken to remove some
private information can you make sure
that this underlying structured
information isn't there anymore so
there's lots of stuff to do with that
what is hue what is a human so this is
something that humanity sort of like
what it means to be a human is kind of
embedded in our technology in a bunch of
different ways this applies in whale
I'll describe here but also as we talk
about AI NML so we started looking at
CAPTCHAs my first kite paper was about
like basically captures are terrible not
surprisingly but what's interesting is
that the same thing with like first in
class second class modalities it shows
up with CAPTCHAs so people thought oh
you could just create an audio version
of the CAPTCHA and play that instead so
so I'm gonna play this and I'm gonna
give you some some hints so this is a
sequence of numbers there's gonna be
some background noise and so the idea is
if you can if you can tell me what
numbers there are then your argument
okay okay how many numbers were there I
think there's more like 10 I'll play it
again I'll play it again with the
visuals showing behind a little bit but
anyway I've been playing the same
CAPTCHA for like 10 years so to me it I
just I know this one so I'm always like
well they can clearly hear this right
then but anyway so this and this is not
an unusually hard audio CAPTCHA
obviously the modality change makes it
different though right so like I can't
just keep staring at like the particular
part of the capture I'm trying to figure
out until I reason with myself about
what number it is right it goes by it's
right anyway so we did this study and
you know basically the audio CAPTCHAs
are a lot harder not surprising what
trick though like I I thought it was
really interesting the the interface
provided makes it even worse on people
like the instruction
from reading it D if the file plays in
another program remember the numbers
return to this page and then type them
in the field below play audio button
browse off play audio button so anyway
just remember those ten numbers and you
can't understand anyway and then type
them in the box later anyway we were
able to improve this a lot just by
changing the interface basically made us
so there's not a lot of different audio
player that you could be in the same box
to control the audio playback but anyway
it just kind of keeps coming up these
these things so takeaway here right
accessibility is hard it means a lot of
different things it's this huge space
and I think it gets less attention than
it should it's converting to and from
any modality right so basically if you
want to accommodate any ability that
people come with and you'd be able to
convert between modalities pretty
fluidly you know it's working in an
environment that's often not prioritized
it's dealing with a legacy of
inaccessible stuff educating people to
use your stuff how do people find it and
then sometimes it means working hard to
develop solutions that aren't as good is
what you could develop if you targeted
the ability that you're converting to in
the first place which is which is tricky
so if we now connect this I'm trying to
bridge over to AI here you know
perception and action feels a lot like
intelligence and so there are actually a
lot of connections between you know
accessibility and modality changes you
know if it's not prioritized you need to
get everything out of the little little
bit of input you have and so machine
learning that scales is actually pretty
important again legacy there's a huge
amount of legacy stuff even if we made
everything accessible from now forward
there just be so much out there and so
scaling with machine learning is
important potentially automatic
personalization and working hard develop
solutions that aren't it's good well AI
is magic so it'll be great a little bit
a little bit less sure about that one
all right so just a few points and I
don't actually have that much time so
I'm just going to run through some of
these points about where I think these
things intersect so one I like to say
the people with disabilities are often
early adopters
earliest users of technologies that in
kind of a IML space for real or often
people with disabilities so the people I
know who have relied on speech
recognition for the long longest are say
people who can't otherwise type I I
think that you know one of the things
that accessibility has really taught me
and I think it's a broader point for HCI
is that you know for lots of reasons
a IML people tend often to be focused on
kind of iterating with a fixed set of
data and then trying to improve models
he would they get out of things I think
there's a huge space that goes beyond
that and a lot of that is not fixing on
a particular problem not fixing on a
particular data set
you know evaluating alternatives
figuring out interaction flows where
yeah this might work for some subset of
people but what's the fallback if it
doesn't and considering all those things
kind of at the same time and then
ultimately figuring out like if what you
produce is even something that is worth
having right maybe the limitations are
so great that it that it it's not and so
I think you know I somewhat facetiously
but you know ml HCI right I feel like
the huge this huge part of what it means
to really develop and deploy real ml
systems is really HCI problems you know
there's some recent work by Kari Chi and
Philip Kuo talk to people about what do
you struggle the most with when using ml
frameworks there's a lot of stuff that
it's like you know parameter tuning and
all this stuff but one big thing is you
know when should I apply ml to what when
will it succeed in will and will it suck
right I think that's an underappreciated
but huge part of developing real ml
systems accessibility is really taught
me about well what does it mean to
develop fair ml lots of ways to think
about this I like to have concrete
examples example in Pittsburgh they had
those little driving robots that were
delivering food in in Pittsburgh and
they had to be pulled off the road
because they fail to do something that
you know intelligent human could do they
could drive to wherever they were going
that was not actually the hard part the
hard part was if they got to an
intersection you know they just sat in
the little curb cut here and so other
people need to use the curb cut right
and they didn't realize that's just one
of the many many different like little
problems you could run into in the real
world that accessibility sort of you
know brings to the fore so there was a
wheelchair user who's trying to go
across the road the other way and they
couldn't get up the ramp because you
know the robot was there and robot
didn't it doesn't move out of the way it
might stop if it's concerned it's gonna
hit somebody but it doesn't move out of
the way and so just a lot me thinking
like I think one of the big challenges
in developing systems for real is how do
we design for ability outliers right so
this is just a random distribution but
there's a lot of people out here right
if you imagine this somehow is people
and it's hard it's hard in an ml world
to do that right because you don't have
enough data right so how do you do that
well maybe we could collect additional
data we could over sample and trying to
predict in advance you know the unknowns
is obviously really hard the unknown
unknowns
and so what do we decide then makes a
solution viable right so how many people
does it need to work on how do we avoid
those mistakes of the past where you
know we've locked into a certain set of
abilities that matter in a certain set
that that we'll deal with later yeah so
it so anyway so some concrete ideas here
you know I think that discovering these
important problems and mapping them on
to something this computational track
constitute a tional tractable collecting
meaningful datasets designing
interactions that make sense all this
sort of is in the purview of HCI right
at least I I think so so here's some
examples of problem definition and data
collection so we in dyslexia detection
and visual assistance so project I
worked on with a postdoc Luther ello was
dyslexia detection problem here is that
there is a huge amount of kids
especially in schools that
have dyslexia we don't know they have
dyslexia and as a result the most common
way they find out as they start failing
in school that goes on for a while and
then eventually someone maybe says hey I
wonder if you have dyslexia and then
they go off maybe to get a two thousand
dollar test and so we wanted to kind of
reduce that burden why I think this this
is not this is a really hard problem but
at the same time most of what was hard
about it was figuring out what data to
collect and then actually collecting the
data and so we loose mostly who knows
who has a linguistics PhD and knows a
lot about dyslexia designed some
exercises based on a bunch of prior work
to elicit differences that she thought
would elicit differences and then
collected you know huge amount of data
from about yeah a few thousand people
many of whom had dyslexia based on
diagnosed test which is really hard to
find right because hold problem is that
you don't know for sure enough to do all
this careful screening to make sure you
don't have people that you actually have
dyslexia you don't think they do kind of
anyway lots of different things there
and built you know classifier that use
pretty simple machine learning to
approve get a reasonably good precision
to recall for a test and that test is
now out in Spain has been used by a
couple hundred thousand people there's
loose with all of some very famous
people you have to do a quiz about
whether you can know who all those
people are and you know developing it
into a training program as well so that
we can not just kind of detect but also
kind of use the detected strengths and
weaknesses to then customize learning
program another data set collection
which I didn't think it was the data set
collection at the time a project where
we release this iPhone app that
crowd-sourced visual question answers so
a blind person could take a picture or
something they wanted to know about
speak and answer or speak a question and
then get an answer back from the crowd
pretty quickly and you know I'm just
gonna run through this we got so many we
released this we got I don't know I
think it was ended up one hundred eighty
thousand questions or something
and there's all over the map you won't
you can you can ask me later if you want
to see more examples like interfaces
that done work
we got like fashion advice we got broken
computers it's like what does this thing
say my computer's broken and now the
screen reader doesn't work right there's
lots of stuff it got a pregnancy test so
apparently there's not accessible
pregnancy tests out there and so after a
while and it took some work again here
dealing with some of the privacy
concerns we were able to release this as
a data set we had a cvpr paper and now
we have a series of workshops at cvpr
where we're challenging people so it's
already this really active community and
visual question-answering in the
computer vision space but now we have a
real task for them and it turns out that
pictures are different like half the
time the thing they're asking about
isn't in the frame
you know the they're worried it's it's
really really challenging and you know
to the the community's credit there's
actually been a lot of real interest in
this which has been exciting we also
realized that one of you know in
basically preparing this data set one of
the challenges is for making something
like this work is helping people better
understand whether they're revealing
private information and so we were able
again with a lot of work to be able to
go through and create a data set of
images with private information with it
private information stripped out so that
then you could set up we could set up a
second challenge of can you predict
whether this image has private
information in or not kind of
interesting this ended up getting into a
couple products so Microsoft seeing AI
Google lookout used our data set part to
train their models one of the things
that it revealed to me is is I think
that there's a I think that in our rush
to do all these fancy things with AI
sometimes we fail to find the kind of
limited scope but practically really
important problems that we could really
make work and so you know general
solutions for visual
question answering or image captioning
it still don't work all that well right
so like Facebook releases just is pretty
cool they released it you know every
image now that gets put on Facebook has
some tags associated with this you can
kind of understand maybe a little bit of
what what's going on you know two people
smiling sunglasses sky outdoor water
obviously you're missing some stuff but
you're still getting some context but
it's interesting when they make mistake
so Mary Morris at Microsoft has this
great example of you know Tillery
Clinton getting on to the stage and it
says you know I am not really confident
but I think it's a man doing a trick on
a skateboard at night and then they
interviewed some people who were blind
and and they said well why do you think
Hillary Clinton would put that on her
web page or Twitter feed or whatever it
was they said well you know she's
probably trying to appear young and hip
and whatever so it could be very
confusing right where some other
problems I think we can actually pick
them out so that they they can work very
reliably so so one thing we've been
looking at which even I was surprised by
how much attention there was about this
but making memes accessible this kind of
the old-school memes we're starting
they're you know moving forward what's
really nice about this this is a very
narrow problem there's only so many meme
templates the text is always impact bold
right so you can make you can make this
work
very very reliably right and so one one
thing is to just you know make it
accessible in the sense we described it
main template and we say what text it is
we've also been working with you know a
more of a design process with
participants about well what would be a
more first-class version of meme
accessibility so I think I have an audio
clip if I don't I'll be really sad put
candy bar in shopping cart without mom
noticing
so that's sort of like success kid made
audio with a little you know some audio
sound effects other thing even from the
viswas data set like it seems very large
and it was very large in scope but we
noticed some patterns right there's all
these real-world devices so there's like
all these appliances that none of them
have accessible interfaces like I'm you
know mentioned this but so we we made a
system that you know uses some
crowdsourcing plus then computer vision
to give feedback and we're able to you
know make vending machines and things
accessible to imagine replacing some of
those with OCR
yes yes yes I always like to end on the
laser cutter
he's like why in person using the laser
cutter yeah yeah boy
with a little bit of extra work and some
we actually put a dollar bill next to
the interface to get it real size we're
able to compute a 3d model of this and
so again kind of the spirit of you know
trans translating it to new modalities
we're able to go into you know a
fabricated tactile version of the
interface we send this off to 3d hubs
you printed and then here's a blind
participant going through the process of
actually using this so you take a
picture the dollars there so we get the
right size stuff they get a little bit
of feedback about that's a whole other
problem yeah how can we assist people
who are blind with photography well
quiet right she takes picture and then
able to attach this little bit of work
to make it so that it's aligned with
some of the boundaries you can feel and
a lot of work that's I'm not covering
here about like well what material
should this be so that you know you it's
reliable robust but you can actually
push through it to the underlying
buttons yeah touch screens there's a
million touch screens out there none of
them are accessible they're probably
around forever we we adapted some of the
ideas from a slide rule but now we have
this little 3d printed finger cap that
you can now do risk for loop free
exploration where if it's a capacitive
screen at least you know it blocks the
your finger from from triggering things
and then if you want to trigger
something depending on the design you
can kind of rock down and trigger it
here's here's a participant it's a
little over the top and that there's all
kinds of things going on but I'll play
the I'll play the video
no finger stain why would you like to
drink target that ridges is our kind of
fake coffee machine
we've got this camera mounted there's
also this dialogue system that's working
behind the scenes that was built up
automatically from videos of anyway lots
of stuff happening to kind of get over
though to get over this legacy problem
whereas if you imagine the coffee
machine if the coffee machine was
accessible from the beginning or you use
a platform that was accessible if it was
Android based or iPhone / iPad based it
would just be accessible but because
they're not then there's all this works
it's it's an interesting tension okay so
I'm out of time so I really think there
is this huge potential though and I
don't think it's you know the the high
Pai that sometimes gets the most press I
think that the hard work of using the
tools we have for machine learning and
applying them discovering real problems
applying them to real problems I think
there's just a huge harvest right so the
AI autumn harvest of things that we can
do and hopefully we can actually get
over some of these hugely hard
long-standing problems and accessibility
and otherwise right so without machine
learning we're not going to - I think
get past the scale problems
the legacy problems some of these
fidelity problems of you know
translating between different modalities
but I think there's a huge opportunity
to make progress and so I'm really
excited about that and so I have some
some ways that you know maybe HDI people
in particular right might might
contribute to this through building
datasets right so building datasets is
hard especially interesting new novel
ones sometimes it means having a whole
project designed just to get out in the
hands of people so that you then you can
get data back from it and lots of other
things uncovering problems and all this
stuff so I'm gonna end here
thank you very much here's a you know
obviously a huge number of people
collaborated on this and I'll take your
questions Thanks
yeah large companies that make the
products that you showed from the iPhone
to microwaves are not devoting the
resources to develop it from the
beginning as you suggest and is it a
market there's not the market there or
that they don't realize what the market
is and are they are there any companies
that you think to a particularly good
job or a bad job of doing it yeah well I
think it's a really great question and
there's a lot of things going on there
you know I I have a lot of respect for
Apple who has done a lot so the iPhones
are accessible in to the degree that
that you saw there although there's
still challenges right so ensuring every
single app is accessible all these
things I as to why companies don't do
more I think there's a million different
reasons right although I did the lewd
earlier back to this idea of his
accessibility of value or not right so
it used to be kind of popular for people
to make this economic argument you know
you have you know a certain number of
people with disabilities you have people
who are aging who you know in a variety
of ways will would start to benefit from
accessibility features I I am less
convinced that that's that's the way to
go I really think it's is this a value
or not there's certainly policy legal
reasons why people might want to ensure
that their stuff is accessible so you
know nothing that you would plan to sell
to the to education markets will get
passed without being at least in theory
accessible there was this great example
of I think Amazon had tried to sell
Kindles to you know all these
universities and they didn't have an
accessible experience or a plan or
anything and so the Department of
Justice basically said you can't use
Kindles as your you know primary way of
delivering textbooks and so there are
those reasons although it's amazing to
me how people seem to really just resist
this idea so the Twitter example of you
know hiding the adding alt text to an
image down three levels of menus before
you can even see that it's an option or
you know recently I think it's Domino's
Pizza Domino's Pizza
you know just fought tooth and nail
against making the
their website accessible and if you look
you know if you look as a sort of
reasonably competent Li technical person
what they were fighting against was
adding alt text and making sure that
there were you know on click instead of
on Mouse down because on Mouse down
assumes a particular input mode like
device whereas on click can work on a
mouse or with the keyboard or with other
things so so I don't know why that kind
of resistance exists it is certainly the
case that it is way harder to do
accessibility after the fact and so and
it's not that hard to get this basic
stuff right like I think it's fun like
it talking to lots of people about like
all these exciting new things we could
do for accessibility
you know like what kinds of crazy new
modalities could we expose like what can
we do oh but like we don't have yet a
reliable way to get people to put alt
text on images there's been a problem
for 25 years anyway 25 years so I'm not
sure yeah related to that what is your
opinion not as a lawyer but as a
professor or Apple employee or maybe not
an Apple employee whether a da requires
this an interfaces and and where do you
think this should be a legal requirement
versus a value of a company I know we
have this discussion years ago but I
want to see yeah well it probably
doesn't surprise people that a lot of
the legislation is a little behind and
probably hasn't completely grappled with
that question so there are so section
508 of the Rehabilitation Act says that
government anything used by the
government basically has to be
accessible and that usually gets
extended to you know public universities
and other things so anyone with
contracts with the government like what
exactly that means to be accessible
right like it's always a little bit you
know it's probably not that first class
experience that we'd love right but you
have to have some way so that's one part
of it the private companies so far my
understanding is that in the
high-profile cases where which have
always been settled right instead of
decided which I think actually
frustrates a lot of people
high-profile cases it tends to be that
the court will rule that the online vert
presents store or whatever else is an
extension of something physical and
therefore the ABA does apply once that
happens then the a DA seems to apply and
you can't exclude people so I think in
another high-profile case target in
target this is a few years ago they had
some offers that were only available on
the website that I think you maybe had
to redeem in the physical site I'm not
sure how it works and then with you know
a pizza piece of shop it's probably
pretty similar right you've got the
online thing that connects to this
physical pizza shop there was a time
when you know we thought that we would
get some more clarity on this so in a
prior administration there was a little
bit more momentum toward the Department
of Justice putting out some actual
guidelines we haven't seen that yet did
you have a understanding so they're
therefore very marginalized
and how do you think that affects
people's vs.
you can drive their inclusion it's a
really fantastic question I I will say
that one of the great things about
working accessibility is that I've I've
gotten to work with a number of people
who think about these issues much more
deeply than I was ever prepared to do
and so I think it's a really important
part of that perspective I definitely
agree that one reason why it's not out
there more is that people don't seem to
know that this is a it's a thing
it's amazing to me like I I was once a
questing' you know accommodations for a
student and you know we winded up
talking to like a vendor and the vendor
is like wow no one ever asked me to
clearly somebody it was a big vendor you
know like it's clearly somebody else has
had this problem it's not documented
it's not somehow out there I don't know
how we overcome that but I definitely
agree that it's part of the the equation
right so you mentioned kind of policy
you know I am very squarely in the
technical side of things and I think
advocacy is this you know the other kind
of leg of the of the stool to make this
actually work but I don't have great
ideas about how we do it
people do band together on social media
I think it's one of the ways you can
kind of point out successes where you
know you can get people that are more
geographically dispersed to kind of come
together around certain issues but you
know it certainly hasn't hasn't you know
solved everything
great question thank ya last question
you did present a little bit of
crowdsourcing as an authority where
other humans are like human could we
like make this more like a social like
you know discussion I mean Brennan's a
machine human interface experiment
that's important but you know we live in
a society with a bunch of people should
we start creating like systems where
humans are more actually supporting each
other and I'm not trying to imply
anything like you know anybody wants to
do or not but clearly we are always
looking for support from other humans
and now we're basically in the machine
we're doing all these very complicated
techniques to try to like envoy maybe
with a human deciding would have been
easier so but I'm talking about a
systemic approach I just like firing a
kind soul that comes in yeah I think
it's I think it's a really great
question a lot of the work that say
Michael was alluding to was was very
much oriented toward making those
connections right and whether that's
paid crowd workers or we also had you
know systems that would connect
volunteers on Twitter or to do different
things that you could do remotely one of
the one of the bits of recent work that
I really like and I've taken inspiration
from is from Cynthia Bennett who is at
University of Washington actually at CMU
with me and now is a postdoc but she has
this model for thinking about disability
called the interdependence model which i
think is really useful in kind of
breaking down that assumption of you
know complete independence being the
end-all goal where I know why people
strive for that but if you look around
none of us are truly independent of each
other and so more more clearly kind of
recognizing that and building from that
in ways that respect people's autonomy
and agency and all of these things I
think is a really fruitful way to move
forward
you
[Applause]